[Musique]
session d élégance de classe charge sous
le tweet de vie d'annie proposant
élargissement de paris incroyable grand
palais oui mais c'est 200 tweets qui de
mépris de tout ce qui est au delà de la
périphérie c'est très étonnant cette
idée de doudou
maintenant les ce sont des parisiens qui
réagissait à cette proposition de
villani d'extension de paris qui était
qui - ne sont pas dérangés avec moscou
j'ai vécu à new york j'ai vécu à londres
c'était ville de 17 18 ou d'habitants
c'est la capitale c'est des villes monde
nous il ya 1,2 million qui enfermaient 2
millions il ya cinq cents ans les deux
parisiens de moins que la sortie d'un
deuxième cas l'identité parisienne alors
si je comprends bien justement identité
mondiale hésite à paris devient le palu
et indique que vous payez le tuba
carhaisien le parigot tous a disparu
mais il est parti c'est comme à londres
le le coq ni le monde ni populaire ni
les avis plus là il est viré de lier
loans and as raison je peux pas je fais
cette parenthèse puisque anne hidalgo et
syndicats nabaa le maire de londres peu
après sur l'élection du maire de londres
a laissé une tribune je me souviens dans
le parisien en disant justement que
l'air des états nations étaient était
terminée et que demain ce sera l'air des
villes monde donc je crois qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose dans l'air
autour de ça mais à mon avis qui ne peut
que produire une forme de guerre civile
larvée qui a commencé déjà
[Musique]